[Music]
this is embarrassing
hi yeah damn right I've seen the video
Fergie singing the national anthem I I
read about it on Twitter you're like oh
you have to see this I feel so bad for
her
I think she's singing and she's like
whoa I think she just got carried away
but you know the national anthem is
arguably the most publicly performed
thing advert who rearranges the national
anthem you just have to be so Fergie I
think you can add you can add a little
bit musically but what she did was
almost just like changing the emotion or
the mood she made a choice she made that
choice and she stuck with it the whole
time I just don't know if it worked out
this way you know Fergie is like always
going to be Fergalicious and I believe
that but the way that she sang it she I
think they called it jazzy we never
heard the first person sing the national
anthem so sure go ahead
like that doesn't bother me but you know
it's cool it's cool to mix it up
do you want to try the national anthem
right now no I'm scared now like Fergie
sings it because I can't I can't even
come close
she's like a diamond in the sky mm
that's a no not at all
not in the least absolutely not I mean I
I will sing the national anthem right
now but I'm also scared I'm down to sing
the national anthem yeah I'll be down to
give it a try I am so confident and
ready to sing the national anthem I'm
literally the best singer ever yeah
[Music]
where's my pitch pipe people where's my
where's my pitch pipe I'm so nervous
it's totally fine I can start whatever
I'll just give it a go by the sides
early why what so proudly we held at the
twilight's last gleaming whose broad
stripes and bright stars I'm so nervous
I was not nervous at all how do people
do this in front of like million people
broadcasting in their face watched were
so gallantly streaming and the Rockets
red glare
the bombs bursting in
[Music]
that our flag was still there oh say
does that star-spangled kid
[Applause]
boy the head
I definitely messed up the words you
know what it's harder than it looks
people I like literally could feel my
nerves and my voice so I cannot begin to
imagine what it's like for the icons of
the world to do this in front of
billions people it's like cool to take
artistic liberty but this movie like run
that by someone and see if it's tasteful
before you go for it
you
[Music]